they're behind him
now they're in front and behind him dude
what a plate
what these plates are really good this
is all captured in camera it has to be
but how
today's episode is brought to you by
morningbrew become smarter in five
minutes with their free daily newsletter
good morning kevin welcome back to
visual effects artists react
and good morning kevin i hope you are
having a great
weekend so far and we're about to make
it better with these clips
i want to show you guys some more
resident evil stuff i watched this and i
just thought of like
nephew vfx
no one was ready no one was ready no one
was ready
for one person to take out a pistol
so basically they eat up their practical
effects budget really fast
and then very quickly everything is just
nephew
this one's bad oh no atmospheric
perspective on that wire
she must be on a blue screen she's not a
great yes she's on a green screen
there's no way they're just popping off
these squibs behind her and she's like
whatever
all right and meanwhile this little
black line
so what do you say nephew effects what
we mean is like there's simple little
things that just
literally looking at what you're working
at like you could fix it like there's
literally reference
in this shot all the person doing this
shot with the cable needs to do is look
at
the color values of that soldier
standing in the doorway
that's the exact same color values that
that black wire should have when it's at
the doorway
they are putting the vfx right on top of
the reference and they're getting it
wrong
here's what i'm trying to look at is
like what killed him was it the
grappling hook that pierces his chest
or was was it the pull and slam into the
table
he's just bumping the table like i i
run into my own furniture at that speed
like pretty frequently
[Music]
classical oh heck yeah umbrella branded
rpgs wow
she has a lot of time to react whoa
there's so much time
those things are literally traveling at
like one mile an hour
a looney tunes cut out a looty two guns
perfectly circular
so is anybody shooting at the same thing
nobody
no one knows what anyone's shooting at
oh there's one guy with like a cool
muzzle flash that's different in the
background shooting through them by the
way
dude look how cg that car looks dude
yeah it's not though
yeah it's definitely not that's real
fire thing and also notice the light on
the ground
yeah it does reflect in the puddles
correctly but there's like a bunch of
harsh matting also
i feel like they actually shot
full-scale cars
on that exact same street that's kind of
a different day
filmed separately and put together but
i'm inclined to think that it's still
the same
spot i agree on that full scale there
might be a little bit of practical
explosion there but i think there's a
totally like
artificial explosion added in after the
fact oh and you can also see a total
like masking line definitely not
there too notice how the fire of the car
is at proper exposure but the fire on
the ground
is slightly grayed down there's a lot of
old movies out there with visual effects
in them and the reason they're so
special
is unlike the films of today there's no
3d programs there's no after effects
there's no simulations
everything here is done with like actual
tricks
which takes me to one of my favorite
things to do on this show which is to
show you guys clips and how you guys
guess
at how they did them so we're kicking
things off with the wizard of oz the
tornado let's take a look
it's a twisted it's a twister oh boy i
was so
scared of that tornado too it's a scary
tornado it's still like it's very iconic
and it's from 1939.
look look at that it's in the background
wait wait oh my okay hold up though
okay they're definitely on a real set
there's no way that's rear projection
that'd be the biggest projection in the
world
oh you see it the parallax doesn't match
the moment the camera started moving
sideways you can see the ground moving
with proper parallax but the distance
was flat this is all captured in camera
it has to be but how
here's the thing i can go to a science
museum and i can see a tornado display
using fan technology you know like
it exists fan technology it's definitely
a created
tornado of some sort like a real tornado
has a lot more like diffusion at its
edge
rather than this which actually looks
very sharp all right nico we gotta know
here's what i did i gotta know it's
crazy because it's so simple
it's a 35 foot long muslin
tube of cloth and it's on like a rolling
gantry at the top
and a stick on the bottom and they're
moving around in opposite directions
and then they have a bunch of fuller's
earth which is basically a very fine
earthy powder and they're spraying it
into the tube from the bottom and around
from the bottom they're spraying it down
from the top and because the cloth
itself is so
loose the dust is not only building at
the tops and bottoms it's also coming
out the sides of the cloth giving you a
smoky tube effect
that's not at all what i would have
expected that's it some of the shots are
miniatures that it cuts to slash
you know set up basically dioramas you
know it's a set it's going it's forced
perspective kind of stuff yeah
like this this i'm pretty sure is a
miniature hold up that's the exact same
view
that's the exact same view as the one
when she was walking by except there's a
fence in front of it they just
use the footage they probably got that
shot the previous day and then on the
next day they just projected it up on
the screen
honestly rear projection doing that sort
of thing like we're talking about
mandalorian and the volume tech
this is what that was back in the day
also their use of fans sells everything
yeah
fan technology fan technology i mean
honestly this movie has
so much groundbreaking stuff in it yeah
i totally took for granted that
the tornado was like a big deal these
have been some
great clips and kevin if you're watching
leave
a comment telling everyone that they
should subscribe
as well thanks kevin don't let us down
kevin i'm i'm
trusting in you you want one more wait
you got one more
i want to see how you guys react to it
[Applause]
oh boy
they're behind him
now they're in front and behind him are
you kidding me
wait what these are ghosts
i am noticing like weird shadows like i
think that wait a second wait a second
these these are being puppeted first off
that's what i'm seeing then
it's it's sticks i'm seeing something
that is excluding them
it's a little black hole i see the black
line every once in a while and so that's
a stick
in the shoe dude this is the original
like vfx technique okay so i am
definitely seeing this
[Laughter]
look all these editing tricks they're
using to make it look like there's shoes
here
so there's definitely some sort of like
merging process going on between fred
astaire dancing here and the shoes
dancing around him
i do agree that the shoes were puppeted
somehow
i feel like i'm gonna give you a little
guidance here okay there's no puppetry
those are people wearing those shoes
okay okay so what are the lines then
they filmed all six people doing this at
the same time dressed in black on a
black stage with black cloth
okay so the only thing you really have
is the shoes so basically just doing a
screen pass from a
shoe dance performance with all these
people when they're doing the circle
the weird lines you're seeing is them
literally painting in
the shoes that are being occluded from
the people as they walk over the other
shoes
so you're seeing the legs effectively
highlighted
of that actor in the front with the
white shoes those are their legs and
they're painting the shoes behind them
manually by hand okay that makes sense
okay
what i still do not get is how they're
able to both get the shoes in front of
him
and behind him at the same time straight
up
old good fashioned hand rotowork
also known as traveling mats back in the
day all right wow this is legitimate
rotoscoping you're talking about
cutting it out and blocking it with
pieces of paint and paper and all that
kind of stuff
we do that today like it's the same
technique
[Music]
it takes his guns out
he's just dancing he's like i think i'm
a gun
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i out of context the scene is
very very funny oh my god oh well that
was a special one
i love old effects they're the best dude
geriatric vfx
they're all so clever and cool and full
of trickery i'm only finding those
because people happen to be like oh this
is a film i watched when i was a kid and
it blew my mind and they shared in the
comments so please
share any like old vfx from before the
era of computers
that feel like magic tricks and we will
come in and we'll figure it out
and we'll show you how it's done so
speaking of older movies there's this
one called
honey i shrunk the kids which came out
the year i was born
i have not seen this movie in years but
there's a lot of things just from like
looking for youtube clips for this real
quick that like suddenly all the
nostalgia started hitting me
the idea behind this movie is that you
have this mad scientist tweaking around
with some
scientific equipment all of his children
end up getting accidentally shrunk down
to like a quarter inch tall
and then they get stuck in the backyard
instead of it being like a jungle they
actually basically created all these
sets
and props but that's not all they did
this bee for instance
it's pretty good around that looks
really good
hey they're doing these shots pretty
well yeah these background shots are
pretty
sweet too actually dude what a plate
what these plates are
really good there's a level of natural
wobble and shake that makes it look kind
of like on a wire or something
it's totally just the dude running with
the camera really
dude running around with a camera hell
yeah the thing that makes it work is the
fact that it's an extremely
wide angle lens because it makes the
environment seem so much bigger which
helps accentuate something that is small
and so for the b they actually did a
couple different things
one they actually had a full-sized b set
that anytime you've seen a close-up of
like a person falling down and landing
on the bee
that's the actual prop they also had a
smaller stop-motion bee
with miniature people on them oh so
those aren't real people on the back of
it for that shot that was a miniature
yeah
and you know it's it's pretty well done
anytime you're seeing like the full b
and whatnot and it's moving really fast
those are miniature people man they're
handling like fuzzy edges and motion
blur so well
yeah i just i found a lot of this very
interesting they sold to me as a child
that these people were small and most of
that was done with giant sets
you know they made a real giant cereal
bowl
set that's so cool because like it's so
mind-boggling
to try and imagine how you would get a
shot like that practically like do you
just need
a super small camera you're actually
kind of touching on a huge problem when
it comes to trying to
film small things and make them feel
small so when you're getting close to
something you're focusing on something
really close
anything out of focus becomes extremely
out of focus giving you very very very
shallow depth of field
you are going to have such a tiny
fraction of a plane that's in focus and
everything else will be
so blurry it's going to be almost
impossible to see they kind of had that
problem on
these movies back in the day where
they're trying to make stuff feel small
but they can't actually do that depth of
field
but recently over the last several years
ant-man they did this
but they actually had proper depth of
field on a lot of these shots
this shot starts out as a normal shot
filmed with a regular camera in a
regular room
the field of view goes really wide but
everything is still relatively in focus
but as we get down to that point where
the focus point is right in front of the
lens
that's when the depth of field really
starts to get shallow and when you're
filming stuff in miniature
this is pretty accurate to what your
lens look like in fact it would be even
more out of focus
exactly you could close on your aperture
enough to get it to be tight
and this is something you can only
achieve with cg cameras you physically
cannot get a lens
into position because just the bulkiness
of the lens would be in the way of
itself
i think my favorite gag out of this
entire movie is when
they just cut to the big looking down
shot and it's like the train just stops
but that's like another brilliant way to
really accentuate the fact that they're
all small is just reminding you they're
doing a whole train fight on
toys
[Music]
oh i just had a horrible dream i was
waking up every day
without today's sponsor morningbrew i
had terrible dreams about
information coming to me through twitter
and
not knowing if i should inform myself on
what's going on in the world of business
and finance it was so confusing and
horrible
all i wanted to do was get out and
thankfully with today's sponsor
morningbrew i can get a free daily
newsletter of witty
relevant and informative information in
the business tech and finance space
that allows me to help start my day
feeling positive
refreshed and ready to go to take on the
world come here world
don't be scrolling through the twitter
trash don't be scrolling through social
media or not knowing what's going on in
the world at the same time
put yourself in a place where you get
your information from a company
that combines the art of journalism with
the art of waking up and having a
constructive and positive day
one article that i read recently was on
the price of lumber if you don't think
lumber's important look at the walls
around you they're probably
made out of lumber and recently it came
down almost 41
since its may record highs despite the
fact that the housing market is still
hot
it's little interesting tips like this
that you learn from morning brew
across business tech and finance they
curate it they make it beautiful they
make it well presented
witty relevant and informative that
makes it entertaining to read
and informative that's the best kind of
news it's the best way to consume your
information
and now i know every day when i wake up
man
sunshine on the horizon so if you're
interested in getting smarter in just
five minutes
click the link in the description below
and get yourself signed up for the
morning brew daily newsletter
thanks so much for watching everyone we
will see you next week or maybe even
tomorrow as well
every sunday we got some baller videos
coming out they're the like
the little sibling of the saturday
videos it's yeah my little brother but
you look at him and he's like
seven feet tall and like four feet wide